some clark county school district
students and staff
may return to campuses next year good
evening thanks for joining us here at
five i'm denise valdez
good evening i'm brian loftis ccsd
reaching that tentative agreement with
the largest
teachers union for potential
face-to-face instruction
now this is for only elementary age
students eight news now reporter
christian drummond on this story joining
us live
outside of rex bell elementary with the
very latest on this big move
kristin
brian the plan focuses on getting pre-k
through third grade students back
into the classroom possibly for the 2021
school year now this is a plan that has
been months in negotiations between the
district
as well as the clark county education
association
the agreement starts the process to
bring students and teachers back
together again
while maintaining health and safety
guidelines dr jarrah says the youngest
students were chosen because data shows
they need the social interaction if
trustees approve the agreement next
month
it may start a phase reopening there's
no timeline though when
other grade levels may return if even at
all next semester
the district plans to follow the
guidance of the southern nevada health
district
while also evaluating the emotional and
educational needs of students
this is the beginning and then we can
start looking to see how many other kids
and then also the educators
as we can start seeing where kids feel
safe families
there's a lot of there's a lot of
variables for us to look at
the district agreed to certain safety
standards and protocols for educators
those include mandatory monthly testing
daily symptoms screening and contact
tracing
providing personal protective equipment
to all employees
and as well strict and thorough
classroom and building sanitation
as well the tentative agreement will be
presented to the board on january 14th
the trustees will also consider a
reopening plan
on that date now until then all staff
who are able to work remotely will
continue to do so
reporting live in las vegas kristin
drummond 8 news now
kristen we know the cdc and american
academy of pediatrics
recommending that schools reopen but how
do our local teachers feel about it and
how will that potentially impact the
plan
okay so
right now a lot of teachers say that
they
are more and more are wanting to get
back
into the classroom according to ccea
and that this plan does provide
flexibility
so that means educators can choose
whether or not they want to be back in
the classroom for in-person instruction
or not so that has been something very
important and something we've
continually heard from educators they
wanted that option so
they have it brian all right
thanks so much kristen so we asked on
social media earlier today
ccsd students and teachers will start to
return to the classroom
for face-to-face learning could happen
sometime after january 15th
do you agree with this decision this one
was really close
51 said yes they are comfortable with it
but
49 say nope they're just not ready brian
denise parents are now weighing in on
this announcement and
we did receive hundreds of comments from
parents on our social media handles
throughout the day
many with contrasting viewpoints yureni
estrada a single mother of five trying
to juggle distance learning with her job
for months she's had to bring her
kindergarten age child
to her office to work so she can assist
him
because of this she's behind on her
workload and can't really focus
on her work and on her older kids at
home she is in
full support of having her five-year-old
back in the classroom
it will help me a lot with work and then
you know not be so
overwhelmed when i get home and i guess
i can't just kind of like keep track
more on the older kids because
when i bring home uh my work then now
i'm doing that instead of
you know helping the kids the other kids
now the other hand some of the parents
that we spoke with want their kids to
remain at home katie buster is also a
mom of five
with two kids that would be impacted by
the decision busser is
concerned about the risks of exposing
her kids
and school staff to the virus no this
isn't easy
this isn't like a picnic this isn't a
vacation
this is very real and very hard but it
is what
is needed and that's that's what a
sacrifice is that's what being a
community is
is being willing to inconvenience
yourself for
your neighbors due to the different
dynamics of each family some
say it is difficult to find a
one-size-fits-all solution
for this challenge